हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है?
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है? आई एम
ऑडिबल एवरीवन। अगर आपको सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही तो प्लीज चैट में यस या नो
बताइए।
बिल्कुल सबको सुनाई दे रही है गाइस।
और स्टूडेंट्स बहुत कम आए हैं। पता नहीं
क्यों
कुछ कह नहीं सकते।
ओके थैंक यू। तो थोड़ा सा एक मिनट का टाइम
वेट 1 मिनट का समय दीजिए। तब वेट करते हैं
कितने स्टूडेंट ज्वाइन होने वाले हैं। अगर
आप लोग नहीं ज्वाइन होने वाले तो फिर
सोचते हैं इन क्लासेस के बारे में भी। अब
की बार जो क्लास थी मैंने जानबूझकर लेट ली
है। उसका कारण यही था कि मैंने आपको डे वन
से एक ही चीज बताई है कि क्लास की
फ्रीक्वेंसी हमेशा आप लोगों पर डिपेंड
करती है। अगर आप लोगों का क्लास में कोई
इंटरेस्ट नहीं है तो फिर मेरे को ब्लेम मत
करो कि सर क्लासेस को फ्रीक्वेंटली लेके
आओ या रेगुलर बेसिस पर बनाओ। क्योंकि आप
लोग टाइम से नहीं आओगे तो मैं आपकी
क्लासेस रेगुलर बेसिस पर नहीं ले सकता।
उसके लिए आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट क्योंकि वन
वीक का टाइम इसीलिए लिया क्योंकि मैं
कंटीन्यूसली आपकी प्रेजेंस देख रहा था
व्यूज रेटिंग आपकी और सब कुछ देख रहा था
बट आप लोगों ने अभी तक वही मेरे जो नॉर्मल
600 स्टूडेंट है 600 वही स्टूडेंट्स मुझे
लग रहा है वही लोग देखते हैं तो मुझे नहीं
पता कि इससे पहले 1000 या 1000 प्लस
स्टूडेंट्स कैसे थे बट अभी
पता नहीं
ये क्या चल रहा है कि आप लोग कहां हो? यस
यू आर इन मॉड्यूल नंबर सिक्स। फंडामेंटल्स
के मॉडल नंबर सिक्स पर हो आप।
तो आप लोगों को इसलिए मैं फिर से बता रहा
हूं। क्लास की फ्रीक्वेंसी सिर्फ
स्टूडेंट्स पे डिपेंड करती है। चाहे
स्टूडेंट्स आप रिकॉर्डिंग से देखिए चाहे
आप लाइव आकर देखिए। बट आपकी फ्रीक्वेंसी
आप पर डिपेंड करती है। और टॉपिक में
इंटरेस्ट ना आने की कोई ऐसी वजह हो नहीं
सकती क्योंकि सारे टॉपिक इंटरेस्टेड हैं।
हर एक क्लास मैं आपके लिए एक
फुल ऑफ कंटेंट लेकर आता हूं कि मेरी क्लास
में कभी भी कंटेंट की कमी नहीं होती। ओके?
और मॉड्यूल्स की रही बात। अभी तक मॉड्यूल
सिक्स में हैं हम और बीच-बीच में जितने भी
मॉड्यूल्स कवर हुए हैं और थोड़े दिन में
पूरी सीरीज को मॉड्यूल वाइज अरेंज कर दिया
जाएगा ताकि आप लोगों के लिए आसानी हो जाए
कि आप लोगों ने क्या-क्या कवर कर लिया और
इसके टाइटल्स थोड़े और ज्यादा क्लियर आपको
देखने को मिलेंगे। और दूसरी बात कि और भी
बहुत सारे मॉड्यूल्स आने वाले हैं। ओके?
यह तो बस छोटा सा मॉड्यूल है। सिक्स हुए
हैं। अगर एक और चीज मैं आपको बता रहा था
कि अगर मॉड्यूल्स
में कुछ भी अगर नई वीडियो और आएगी जैसे कि
फॉर एग्जांपल हमने मॉड्यूल सिक्स कवर कर
लिया लेकिन इन फ्यूचर्स या अपकमिंग
क्लासेस में हमने मॉड्यूल मॉड्यूल सिक्स
से रिलेटेड कोई भी अगर और कोई भी टॉपिक
पढ़ाया है तो डायरेक्टली वो उसी मॉड्यूल
के अंदर ऐड कर दिया जाएगा ताकि आप लोगों
के लिए चीजें आसान हो जाए। तो प्लीज
मुझे बस एक बार मशीन को ऑन करने का टाइम
दीजिए क्योंकि मैं अभी मशीन को ऑन नहीं कर
पाया हूं अपनी तो जस्ट गिव मी सम टाइम अब
अपनी काली मशीन को ऑन कर लेते हैं क्योंकि
प्रैक्टिकल सेशन हमारा कंप्लीटली क्योंकि
आज जो हम देखने वाले हैं वॉइस मेल
कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल के बारे में देखने वाले
हैं और आज हमारा जो शिप प्लस आरटीपी का जो
एक सेक्शन है जो अनइंकिप्टेड चाहे आपका
वॉइस हो चाहे आपका शिप का हैंडशक हो जो
आपका अनइंकिप्टेड मॉड्यूल सॉरी जो आपका जो
अनइंकिप्टेड वाला पार्ट था या जो
अनइंकिप्टेड की जो बोले कि हम
उस सेक्शन में थे वह आपका कंप्लीट हो
जाएगा आज जो नेक्स्ट क्लास होगी तो अगर आप
लोगों का इंटरेस्ट रहा तो मैं नेक्स्ट
क्लास कल ही ले लूंगा और जो नेक्स्ट क्लास
होगी आपकी वह आपकी
एक इंक्रिप्टेड पार्ट, एक अनइकिप्टेड
पार्ट हम सेकंड फेज पर या सेकंड सेक्शन पर
काम करेंगे। सिर्फ ओवर टीएलएस प्लस में
आरटीपी ट्रैफिक को एनालिस करना देखेंगे।
बट दिस टोटली डिपेंड्स ऑन यू गाइस कि आप
लोग क्या चाहते हो।
क्योंकि देखिए मैं अपने ऑफिस से जस्ट अभी
आया हूं और आते ही मैं आपके लिए क्लास ले
रहा हूं।
चलिए फिर एक काम करते हैं हम हम ओपन करते
हैं कि हमने लास्ट क्लास में जो क्लास
नंबर 57 थी उसमें हमने देखा था कि जो
ऑडियो को एक्सट्रैक्ट कर रहे थे हमने दो
टेक्निक देखी थी एक तो व एक्स आर्क के
थ्रू कि जो ऑडियो एक्सट्रेक्शन था जो हमने
sh प्लस आरटीपी के अंदर जब हम ऑडियो
एक्सट्रेक्शन देखा था एक तो व्स आर के
थ्रू देखा था नॉर्मल कॉल टू पार्टीज का।
यह चीज हमने वायरस आर के थ्रू देखा था।
दूसरी टेक्निक और बच गई थी हमारी। एक
टूल्स है। उसके थ्रू भी हम कर सकते हैं।
मैं उस टेक्निक को कवर करने वाला हूं। उस
टेक्निक में आपका आपका आता है। आपको क्या
करना है? आपको
Google पे जाना है। Google पे आपको सर्च
करना है PCP टू वेव। आपको सर्च करना है
PCP टू वेव।
PCP टू वेव। मैं आपको यह लिंक बता दूंगा।
यह सर्च करना। मैं आपको ज़ूम कर देता हूं।
यह चीज सबको दिखाई दे रही होगी। पिक कैप
टू वेव यह देखिए। यहां पर दिखाई दे रहा है
आपको पिक कैप टू वेव आरटीपी टू ऑडियो वेव।
अभी यहां पर दो चीजें हैं। एक तो आपका गीब
लिंक है। जहां से आप क्या कर सकते हो?
यहां पर क्लिक करोगे और यहां पर गीब फाइल
को आप डाउनलोड कर सकते हो या वो कर सकते
हो। इंस्टॉल कैसे कर सकते हो? यहां पे हम
कॉपी क्या करने वाले हैं? हम कॉपी करने
वाले हैं कि सीएलआई ये रहा https इसको
कॉपी करेंगे हम। यहां पर जस्ट इसको हमने
कॉपी किया। ओके यहां पर हमने क्या नो सॉरी
गेट अब कॉपी नहीं कर रहे हम यहां पर वेट
वेट गाइस
प्लीज मैं एक बार देख लेता हूं कि यही है
क्या?
हम हम
यह तो आपका एक तरीका यह है। यहीं से आप कर
सकते हो। यह चीज मैं आपको बताई भी थी। तो
बताया था क्या मैंने? यह यह वाला पार्ट
आपको बताया था।
यह वाला पार्ट आपको कवर किया था।
बताइए यह पार्ट मैंने आपके लिए कवर किया
था। नहीं किया था? यह टेक्निक कवर की थी।
बिल्कुल। तो इसके लिए हम चलते हैं अभी गिट
रिपो। इसकी गिट रिपो यही है। और हमें इसके
लिए क्या करना है? हमें जाना है इसके लिए
सैंपल्स। आई थिंक वी नीड टू क्लोन दिस वन।
हमने
क्या किया था?
ओके अब एक काम करते हैं इसको
यह रहा। इसको कॉपी करते हैं क्योंकि यह
फाइल मैं ऑलरेडी कॉपी कर चुका हूं। मैंने
जब इसको कॉपी किया था एक काम करते हैं।
अभी मैं सीडी करूंगा तो यह ऑलरेडी इसको
डाउनलोड करना है आपको। बेसिकली आपको क्या
करना है? डाउनलोड करना है अपने मशीन के
अंदर। मैं सीडी करता हूं। डाउनलोड्स के
अंदर जाता हूं।
डाउनलोड्स के अंदर जाता हूं। मैं क्रॉस
चेक करूंगा तो आपको मिल जाएगी यह फाइल। यह
फाइल आपको मिलेगी यहां पर कहां पर? वेज
माय फाइल दिस वन। ओके। Windows पावर जा
jवा fग ओपन 35 रन। एक काम करते हैं। यहां
पर चलते हैं। चेक कर लेते हैं एक बार।
चलिए हम एक काम कर लेते इसको डाउनलोड ही
कर लेते हैं।
हम इसको क्या करते हैं? डाउनलोड कर लेते
हैं। यहां पर भी ये फाइल है क्या?
वीडियोस यह रहा यह रही यह रही देखो यह रही
जब इसको हम डाउनलोड करेंगे ना इस तरीके की
फाइल आपको देखने को मिलेगी जस्ट मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं एक बार हम सीडी डाउनलोड्स
के अंदर चलते हैं एक बार
उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है डब्ल्यू गेट
गेट क्लोन भी कर सकते हो डब्ल्यू गेट और
उसके बाद https वाली बात थी देखते हैं हम
इसको कर सकते हैं नहीं कर सकते पेस्ट फॉर
क्लिपबोर्ड सर गेट हब है तो डब्ल्यू गेट
से हम इसको नहीं कर सकते कर सकते हैं। कर
सकते हैं। देखते हैं। आई थिंक एलएस यस
यस यस यस नो नो नो वी आर नॉट एबल टू डू
इट। क्योंकि उसके लिए हमें गेट क्लोन करना
पड़ेगा। और एक और टेक्निक थी। मैं
डायरेक्टली इसको चलता हूं।
चलो इसको मैं गेट क्लोन किया और एलएस
डाउनलोड कर लिया। गेट क्लोन करने के बाद
हमारे पास यह फाइल आ जाएगी कहां पर? यह
रहा पिकैप टू। ठीक है? गेट क्लोन कर लिया
हमने। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। गेट क्लोम
करने के बाद हम एक बार मैं क्लियर कर देता
हूं स्क्रीन को आपको समझ में आ जाएगा। और
हम देखते हैं अभी सबको स्क्रीन दिखाई दे
रही है ना? सबको स्क्रीन दिखाई दे रही है?
गाइस सबको स्क्रीन दिखाई दे रही है?
या थोड़ा सा ज़ूम करना है। चलो, मैं इसको
ज़ूम कर देता हूं। तो, हम एक काम करते हैं।
इसको देखते हैं। अभी लिस्ट किया इसको और
हम इसको परमिशन देंगे। सीएच मोड देन उसके
बाद हम परमिशन देंगे प्लस एक्स उसके बाद
पिकैप
पिकैप टू वेब इसको परमिशन दे दी एलएस किया
परमिशन देने के बाद अब इसको हम रन करते
हैं इसको रन करने का तरीका क्या है रन
करने एक बार हम एलएस हफन
एल करते हैं क्या हम इसके लिए परमिशंस देख
पा रहे हैं ओके इसको हम परमिशन सेग्रगेट
देने का फायदा नहीं क्योंकि डायरेक्टरी है
सॉरी फॉर दैट हम एक काम करते हैं इसके
अंदर पी कैप चलते हैं एलस इसके अंदर क्या
है फाइल्स
एक्सक्टली मैं इसको भूल गया इसका एक पाथ
था काम करने का तरीका ओ आई एम
यह वह तरीका नहीं है मैं उसको भूल गया एक
मिनट का टाइम दीजिए अभी जस्ट आपके सामने
करता हूं
चलिए इसको मैं नेक्स्ट क्लास लास्ट में
बता दूंगा क्योंकि अभी मैं भूल गया
एग्जैक्ट पाथ क्या था? एग्जैक्ट इसको
तरीका भूल गया कहां से मैंने इसको पुल आउट
किया था। तो आपको दिखा देता हूं परफॉर्म
करके दिखा देता हूं ताकि आप लोगों को ना
लगे कि सर ऐसे ही क्लास में वो कर रहे
हैं। टाइम वेस्ट कर रहे हैं। तो हम एक काम
करने वाले हैं अभी हम चलते हैं अपनी जहां
पर मैंने इसको क्लोन पहले से किया हुआ है
या पहले से इसको डाउनलोड किया हुआ है। तो
मैं काम डाउनलोड वाले डायरेक्टरी में चलता
हूं। इसको हम रिमूव कर देंगे। पहले एलएस
अभी जब मैं इसको रन करूंगा यह रहा pिकैप
टू यह रहा यह रहा हिट एंटर किया तो यहां
पे बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस आ रहे हैं। पिककैप टू
वेव इज अ सिंपल यूटिलिटी टू मेक इट इज़ टू
एक्सट्रैक्ट द ऑडियो फ्रॉम ए पिककैप ओके
डिपेंडेंसीज इसकी क्या है? एपीटी गेट
इंस्टॉल्ड व्हाई टीs शार्क यह डिपेंडेंसी
है आपकी। उसके बाद यह देखो एम इंस्टॉल्ड
वसार शॉक। यह इसकी डिपेंड है। इट
रिक्वायर्स टी शार्क टू बी इंस्टॉल्ड ऑन द
सिस्टम इफ ए कोdक अदर देन पीसीएमए और
पीसीएमय इट इज यूज्ड देन द स्क्रिप्ट विल
अटेम्प्ट टू यूज़ एफएस सीएलआई टू डिकोड एंड
क्रिएट ए वेव। तो ये सारी चीजें आप खुद से
पढ़ सकते हो। हमें क्या करना है? हम कैसे
एक्सट्रैक्ट कर सकते हैं? मैं आपको दिखाता
हूं। एक्सट्रैक्ट करने के लिए हमें क्या
करना पड़ा है? उस कॉल को लेके आना पड़ेगा।
यहां पर एक डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट करते हैं।
हम डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट करने की जरूरत नहीं।
हम एलएस लिस्ट आउट करते हैं यहां पर। और
यह मेरा नॉर्मल होम डायरेक्टरी है। हम
चलते हैं होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर ओपन करते
हैं। यह हमारी होम डायरेक्टरी है यहां पर।
तो यहां पर आपको देखने ये रहा पीकैप टू
वेव ये आपकी फाइल है। तो हम एक काम करते
हैं। यहां पर कॉपी कर लेते हैं अपनी उसको।
यह रहा अपनी शिप आरटीp ये रहा। इसको हम
जस्ट एंड कॉपी एंड पेस्ट कर लेंगे।
क्योंकि मेरे में अलाउड है। तो मैं यहां
पर क्या कर दिया? पेस्ट कर दिया। तो यहां
पर नॉर्मल कॉल टू पार्टी डॉट पीcaप फाइल
यहां पर आ गई। तो हम क्या करने वाले हैं?
अभी इसको स्क्रीन को क्लियर करता हूं। और
कैसे एक्सट्रैक्ट कर सकते हैं? यह बहुत
काम आने वाला है। अभी आज की क्लास में
बहुत काम आने वाला है। पीकैप टू वेव उसके
बाद आपको क्या करना है? उसके बाद आपको यह
नॉर्मल कॉल इसको पिककैप। उसके बाद हमने
क्या लिखा? नॉर्मल कॉल एक पैरामीटर दे
दिया। और उसके बाद हम क्या कर देते हैं?
इसको हिट एंटर कर देते हैं। ओके? यह डॉट
वेव फाइल के अंदर वो कर देगा नॉर्मल
अंडरस्कोर हमने क्या कर दिया कॉल
और हिट एंटर कर दिया इट विल टेक टाइम इट
विल क्रिएट ओके इसने ऑपरेशन कंप्लीट कर
दिया यहां देखो गया स्ट्रीम वन स्ट्रीम टू
स्ट्रीम थ्री स्ट्रीम चार टोटल चार
स्ट्रीम है पहले लिस्ट आउट किया हमने देखो
नॉर्मल कॉल टू वेव डोर ये बन गई यहीं पर
तो हम चलते हैं यहां पर ये रहा ओके सॉरी
ये बाय मिस्टेक क्रिएट हो गया यहां पर
चलते हैं यहां देखिए अब यहां पर मैं एक
काम करता हूं अभी इसको आप सुनो तो आई विल
ट्राई कि आप एक बार सुनने की कोशिश करना
इसमें देखो डबल क्लिक किया
सुने तो बताना
कुछ सुनाई दिया
नहीं सुनाई दिया बिकॉज़ इसकी प्रॉब्लम क्या
लinक्स की प्रॉब्लम है। यह था। इस फाइल को
मैं एक काम करता हूं। एक्सट्रैक्ट हमने
एक्सट्रैक्ट कर लिया। इसको कॉपी करते हैं
हम। कॉपी करके पेस्ट करते हैं बाहर। क्या
हम यहां पर कुछ सुन पाएंगे? यहां पर पेस्ट
करते हैं। एक बार पेस्ट यहां पर पेस्ट हो
गई। हमारी फाइल है। नॉर्मल कॉल। यह आ गई।
इधर। मैं इसको इधर कर देता हूं। देखो यहां
पर इसके अंदर। यह रही यहां पर यह रही।
इसको डबल क्लिक किया। अब बताना सेम फाइल
है यह।
वैसे सुने तो मुझे बताना
चैट में बताओ कुछ सुनाई दिया आप लोगों को?
नहीं सुनाई दिया अभी भी बताइए
सुनाई दिया ना तो अभी एक काम करते हैं
इसको बंद करते हैं और हम अभी हम एक
नेक्स्ट सिनेरियो पे काम करने वाले हैं।
नेक्स्ट सिनेरियो क्या है कि वॉइस मेल ओके
वॉइस मेल वॉइस मेल को कैसे एनालाइज कर
सकते हैं? एक चीज मुझे यह बताइए जब भी हम
वॉइस मेल को एनालाइज करेंगे तो उसमें क्या
सिनेरियो हो सकता है? जब एक वॉइस मेल को
एनालाइज किया जाएगा तो उसमें क्या
सिनेरियो हो सकता है? आप सोच के बताइए कि
वॉइस मेल में क्या होता होगा?
वॉइस मेल में क्या होता होगा? बताओ।
किसी को कोई आईडिया? जल्दी से चैट में
बताइए। वॉइस मेल में क्या होता होगा?
वॉइस मेल में क्या होता होगा?
क्या होता होगा बताइए जल्दी से। कोई नहीं
बताएगा। देखो सीधी सी बात है। यूजर वन था
या कॉलर वन था। कॉलर वन ने किसको किया?
कॉल? कॉलर टू को। यूजर टू को। तो बीच में
क्या होता है? सर्वर होता है। तो अगर
सर्वर को पता है हां बिल्कुल राइट। सर्वर
को पता है कि जो कॉलर टू है जिसको कॉल
करनी है कॉलर वन को जो कॉलर टू है अभी वह
ऑफलाइन है। लेकिन अगर कॉलर टू के लिए वॉइस
मेल कॉन्फ़िगर है या जब जिस सर्विस का यह
यूज कर रहे हैं वप के लिए अगर उन्होंने
वॉइस मेल को कॉन्फ़िगर किया हुआ है। मतलब
भले ही ऑफलाइन है आपका यूजर टू या कॉलर टू
लेकिन उन्होंने वॉइस मेल सर्विस को
एक्टिवेट किया हुआ है सर्वर के ऊपर। तो उस
केस में क्या होगा कि सर्वर को पता है कि
जो कॉलर बी है वह ऑफलाइन है। लेकिन जैसे
ही आप क्या करते हो? कॉल इनिशिएट करते हो।
कॉल इनिशिएट करते ही कॉलर ए क्या करेगा?
कॉलर ए ने कॉल इनिशिएट किया। कॉल इनिशिएट
करते ही सर्वर के पास रिक्वेस्ट की। सर्वर
ने देखा हो कि कॉल इनिशिएट करने की कोशिश
की जा रही है। लेकिन उसको साथ के साथ यह
भी पता है कि जो आपका जो कॉलर भी है वो
ऑफलाइन है। तो और एक चीज और उसको कंफर्म
हुई कि इसके यहां पर एक वॉइस मेल जो
सर्विस है वो भी एक्टिवेट है। कॉन्फ़िगर की
गई है। तो सेम टाइम सर्वर आपको क्या बोलता
है कि आपको सुनाई देता होगा कि जो जिस भी
यूजर को आपने ट्राई करने की कोशिश की है,
कॉल करने की कोशिश की वो अनअवेलेबल्स है।
तो अगर आप उसके लिए कोई मैसेज छोड़ना
चाहते हो तो आप प्लीज यहां पर वॉइस ईमेल
में छोड़ सकते हो और उसके बाद क्या है कोई
हैश पाउंड या कोई भी साइन आपसे क्लिक
करवाता है उसके बाद आप रिकॉर्ड करते हो और
कॉल एग्जिट हो जाती है यही होता है और
आजकल आपने ज्यादातर क्या चीज देखी होगी
ज्यादातर आपने देखा होगा कि यह किसके केस
में है iPhone में तो नॉर्मल है यह कि
आपने किसी को कॉल किया थोड़ी देर तक बैल
गई उसके बाद क्या की वो आपको वॉइस मेल के
लिए क्या कर देता है ओपन कर देता है कि आप
वॉइस नोट छोड़ सकते हो। तो सेम वही चीज
है। उसमें क्या है कि कॉल जा रही है।
ऑफलाइन नहीं है। बट यहां पर क्या है? वी
आर नॉट श्योर कि वह ऑफलाइन है भी या नहीं
क्योंकि बीच में सर्वर है। समझ में आया कि
मैं क्या कहने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं?
समझ में आया मैं क्या कहने की कोशिश कर
रहा हूं? तो यह वो फाइल है। उन दोनों की
बीच यह आपकी क्या है? वॉइस मेल की फाइल
है। तो इसको भी हम एनालाइज करते हैं। गो
टू टेलीफोनी शिप फ्लो। दीज़ ऑल आर द फ्लो।
हमने इसको हाईलाइट किया। हमने हम किसके
ऊपर गए? फ्लो सीक्वेंस। अब फ्लो सीक्वेंस
में गए तो यहां पर ध्यान से देखिए। सबसे
पहले क्या हुआ? यूजर वन कौन सा था?
192.168.20.132
और यह आपका सर्वर है। इसने पहले अपने आपको
रजिस्टर किया। यह मुझे बताने की जरूरत
नहीं है। रजिस्टर किया अन ऑथराइज
रिप्लाई आया। फिर से रजिस्टर किया। 200
ओके हो गया। इन पे ज्यादा ध्यान नहीं
देना। ओके? और उसके बाद क्या है? इनवाइट
एसडीपी पैकेट भेजा कि मुझे कॉल करनी है।
किसको?
देखो यहां पर एसडीपी पैकेट को अगर आप
एनालाइज करोगे तो यहां पर देखिए यह रहा
एसडीपी पैकेट। इनवाइट मैसेज भेजा। मैसेज
हेडर में क्या था? इसने कॉल किसको करना
है? यह रहा 222 मतलब यूजर बी को कॉल करना
है। यह चीज आपको पता है। और इसने सर्वर का
आईपी एड्रेस डाला है। ये चीज़ मुझे बिल्कुल
एक्सप्लेन करने की जरूरत नहीं क्योंकि ये
चीज़ हम देख चुके हैं। तो इट्स ओके। फाइन।
हम एक काम करते हैं। चलते हैं। कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं। नहीं हमें इसका आईडिया है।
तो इन्होंने क्या किया? सर्वर ने अन
ऑथराइज एक्सेस भेजा। मतलब अन ऑथराइज भेजा।
401 उसके बाद जो कॉलर वन था उसने
एकनॉलेजमेंट दिया। फिर से उसने इनवाइट
एसडीपी क्योंकि उसने डाइजेस्ट चैलेंज दिया
था। यहां पर चैलेंज सॉल्व किया। MD5 हैश
वैल्यू पास की विद पासवर्ड। पासवर्ड की
एमडी5#श वैल्यू को पास किया। उसके बाद
सर्वर ने रिप्लाई में क्या किया? 100
ट्राइंग। ओके? यह आपको पता ये आता था।
उसके बाद देखो सडनली सर्वर ने 200 ओके
एसडीपी भेज दिया। सर्वर ने 200 ओके एसडीपी
भेज दिया। आप मुझे एक चीज बताइए। अगर आप
लोगों ने लास्ट क्लास में पढ़ा होगा जब
मैंने आपको पढ़ाया था। अगर ध्यान से आप
लोगों को याद होगा 200 ओके एसडीपी कब आता
था? यह मेरा आप लोगों से सवाल है। जो यह
रिप्लाई था यह कब आता था? 200 ओके एसडीपी
का रिप्लाई कब आता था? मेरा सवाल है।
जल्दी से बताइए चैट में। अब पता चल जाएगा
कि आप लोगों को कितनी नॉलेज है। आप लोगों
ने कितना पढ़ा? जल्दी से बताओ।
जल्दी से बताओ कि आप लोगों ने कितना पढ़ा
है और कितना आप लोगों को याद है अभी जल्दी
से बताओ
गाइस क्विकली क्विकली
यह कब आता था 200 ओके एसडीपी के जो अभी आ
गया
जब हमने एनालाइज किया था लास्ट क्लास में
टू कॉलर दो लोगों की बातचीत को कन्वर्जेशन
को हमने एनालाइज किया था तो कब आया था 200
ओके एसडीपी मैसेज और अभी यह आया तो इसका
मतलब क्या है या कब आता था बताओ मेरे को
कब आना चाहिए 200 ओके एसडीपी मैसेज बताइए
बताइए जल्दी से
कनेक्शन कनेक्ट होने के बाद आता था
या अमान शेख कॉल पिकअप कप करने के बाद आता
था। बताओ कब आता था?
ध्यान से सोचोगे कब आता था?
कॉल पिकअप करने के बाद आता था। अगर याद
आपको याद होगा कि जब सामने वाली पार्टी है
या जो यूजर टू है कॉल पिकअप कर लेगा तब
आता था। बट यहां पर क्या हुआ? सर्वर को
पता है कि सामने वाली पार्टी ऑफलाइन है।
इसलिए उसने 200 ओके एसडीपी पे भेज दिया।
उसके बाद सर्वर ने आपके जो यूजर ने
एकनॉलेजमेंट भेज दिया वही एसडीपी की
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन अपडेट कर लिया। फिर 200 ओके
फिर आरटीपी
दो आरटीपी पैकेट यहां पर भेजे गए। यहां पे
देखो आरटीपी पैकेट यह सर्वर को भेजा गया।
यहां सर्वर से क्योंकि सर्वर ने बोला हुआ
उसके बाद यह रहा एक पाउंड साइन डीटीएमपी
मैं आपको आगे पढ़ाऊंगा। यह क्या होता है?
आरटीपी फिर पाउंड साइन और इसके बाद फिर से
आरटीपी बाय मैसेज 200 ओके रीरजिस्टर
प्रोसेस।
रीजिस्टर प्रोसेस समझ में आया रीरजिस्टर
प्रोसेस अगर आप इसको देखोगे यह चीज समझ
में आई कि यहां पर क्या हुआ
ठीक है यहां पर क्या हुआ सर्वर ने कुछ
मैसेज दिया होगा चलो आपको मेरी बात समझ
में नहीं आएगी चलो यह बात भी हम समझ लेते
हैं कैसे समझेंगे मैं आपको बताता हूं चलो
इट्स ओके फाइन यहां पर हम क्या करते हैं
मिनिमाइज करते हैं यहां पर चलते चलते हैं।
पहले इनको डिलीट कर लेते हैं। तो यह भी हम
एनालाइज कर देते हैं अभी
क्योंकि अदर आपको ऐसे बातें समझ में नहीं
आएंगी। लेकिन मैं आपको बताता हूं। देखो
इसको मैं पहले डिलीट करता हूं।
यह डिलीट करता हूं। यह डिलीट करता हूं।
डिलीट करता हूं। डिलीट करता हूं। यह डिलीट
करता हूं। यह डिलीट करता हूं। यह डिलीट
करता हूं। यह यहां पर रखते हैं। आउटपुट
ऐसा और कुछ तो नहीं बच गया। कुछ गलत चीज
डिलीट नहीं होनी चाहिए। परफेक्टली फाइन।
अभी एक और काम करते हैं हम। इस फाइल को
कॉपी कर लेते हैं क्योंकि हमें यह फाइल भी
चाहिए शिप आरtp और इसको भी हम क्या कर
लेते हैं? कॉपी कर लिया हमने। कॉपी किया
एंड पेस्ट इंटू आवर
मशीन। तो, हम इसके लिए एक काम कर लेते
हैं। पहले एक फोल्डर क्रिएट कर लेते हैं।
क्रिएट फोल्डर और वप हम एंटर किया। वही
फोल्डर क्रिएट कर लिया। और इसके अंदर हम
क्या कर देते हैं? इसको पेस्ट कर दिया। और
इसी इसी प्रकार से यह जो टूल था इसको भी
यहां पर हम पेस्ट कर देते हैं। जो
स्क्रिप्ट थी आपकी पिकप टू वेव कंट्रोल
एक्स और यहां पर इसके अंदर ही पेस्ट कर
देते हैं। अच्छा हो गया और यहां पर हम
टर्मिनल को ओपन कर लेंगे। तो एक बार
स्क्रीन को क्लियर कर देता हूं मैं और
यहां पर देखते हैं अभी हम सीडी उसके बाद
वप
वप यहां पे लिस्ट आउट करेंगे। ये रहा अभी
हम क्या करने वाले हैं? पीकैप टू वेव उसके
बाद कॉल टू वॉइस मेल डॉट पीcaप और हमने
क्या लिखा वॉइस मेल ठीक है वॉइस मेल हिट
एंटर यह देखिए जल्दी से इसने कंप्लीट कर
दी फाइल यहां पर देखोगे यह बन गई कितनी
वॉइस टोटल कितनी वॉइस मिल है वेव वन वेव
टू मिक्स है यह तो सबसे पहले हम स्टार्ट
करते हैं वेव वन से तो अभी इसको हम इसको
भी और यह भी क्लिक किया और यह भी क्लिक
किया और इसको कहां करते हैं? सभी को हम ले
चलते हैं इधर एक साथ कंट्रोल सी हम इसको
करेंगे। कॉपी किया और यहां पर हम फोल्डर
क्रिएट कर लेते हैं। यहां पर एक एक यहां
पर फोल्डर क्रिएट करते हैं।
ऑडियो
यहां पर हमने पेस्ट कर लिया। पेस्ट कर
लिया और अभी इसको हम रन करेंगे। और इससे
पहले वाली को हम डिलीट कर देते हैं। और आप
लोग बताना सुन के कि क्या सुनाई देगा।
स्टार्ट करें।
आर यू रेडी गाइस? स्टार्ट करें। सुनना
ध्यान से सुनना। बिल्कुल मैं साइलेंट
रहूंगा। बिल्कुल ध्यान से।
हम्म
शायद कुछ सुनाई नहीं दिया क्योंकि ये हम
लinक्स मशीन में कर रहे हैं तो शायद हो
रही है। तो एक काम करते हैं। चलो इसका भी
हम सशन निकाल लेते हैं। आप सबको पता हम
कैसे कर सकते हैं इसका भी सशन। इसका सशन
निकालने के लिए अभी हमें क्या करना
पड़ेगा? इस टैब पे जाते हैं। इस टैब पे
जाके हमें क्या करना है? हमारा पिकैप टू
पिकैप टू वेव
यह भी और यहां पर जाते हैं और इस पे क्लिक
किया। जैसे इस पे हम क्लिक करेंगे वॉइस
क्लियर नहीं आ रहा था। बिल्कुल क्रिएट
न्यू सेशन ऐड फाइल और यहां हम चलते हैं
किसके ऊपर दिस पीसी ओके दिस पीसी नहीं
हमें जाना है किसके ऊपर
बाय डेस्कटॉप
डेस्कटॉप पे जाएंगे शिप आरटीपी कॉल टू
वॉइस मेल ओपन इट विल एक्सट्रैक्ट ऑल द
फाइल्स एंड यह रहा मेल कॉल इसको हम क्या
करते हैं डाउनलोड करते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है इसको भी डाउनलोड किया और इसको भी
डाउनलोड किया तो कोई बात नहीं वर्चुअल
मशीन की वजह से हो गया होगा लेकिन
वन फाइल इसको
द पर्सन एक्सटेंशन 2
इज अनवेलेबल प्लीज लीव योर मैसेज आउट द
टोन व्हेन डन हैंग अप और प्रेस द की
गाइस अभी वॉइस क्लियर आई
गाइस अभी वॉइस क्लियर आई? बिल्कुल साफ-साफ
सुनाई दिया।
बिल्कुल साफ-साफ सुनाई दिया सबको।
चलो दूसरे वाले और सुनते हैं।
पर्सन एक्सटेंशन टू टू टू टू इज अनवेलेबल
प्लीज लीव योर मैसेज आफ्टर टोन व्हेन डन
हैंग अप और प्रेस द की
थैंक यू गुड बाय
यह भी क्लियर सुनाई दिया
गेटिंग सबको सुनाई दिया
बिल्कुल सुनाई दिया बताओ
और यह था आपका वॉइस मेल समझ में आया वॉइस
मेल कैसे एनालाइज हुआ
यहां पर भी आप कर सकते हो ऐसे मैं इसको
क्लोज करूं तो यहां पर देखोगे अगर आप ऑल
फ्लो सीक्वेंस नीचे मुझे क्लोज करना है
प्ले स्ट्रीम
द पर्सन एक्सटेंशन टू टू टू टू इज
अनवेलेबल प्लीज लीव योर मैसेज आफ्टर द टोन
व्हेन डन हैंग अप और प्रेस द की
दिस कॉलर वन वेलकम टू एकडमी
थैंक यू गुड बाय
डन
इट्स ओके फाइन इसको भी हम क्या कर देते
हैं अभी के लिए क्लोज करते हैं तो ये थी
हमारी वॉइस मेल ये थी हमारी वॉइस मेल को
एनालाइज करना यह था हमारा वॉइस मेल को
एनालाइज करना अब उसके अलावा क्या है
नेक्स्ट आता है हमारा क्या
कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल को एनालाइज करना आपके
कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल को एनालाइज करना। अब जो
कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल है उसमें क्या होता है कि
कोई भी कभी भी आके जा सकता है। मतलब कि दो
लोग बातचीत कर रहे हैं कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल में
कोई भी थर्ड पार्टी तीसरा व्यक्ति भी
ज्वाइन कर सकता है। फोर्थ भी ज्वाइन कर
सकता है। फिफ्थ भी ज्वाइन कर सकता है।
लेकिन मेरे कहने का मतलब क्या है? कि अगर
कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल में एक यूजर की कितनी
स्ट्रीम होंगी? दो। तीन यूजर की छह होगी।
चार यूजर की आठ हो जाएंगी। मैं बोल रहा
हूं आपको तो हम बात कर रहे हैं यह रहा sh
प्लस आरटीपी कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल थ्री पार्टीज
को हम क्या करने वाले हैं एनालाइज करने
वाले हैं थ्री पार्टीज की कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल
को हम एनालाइज करने वाले हैं और यहां पर
हम क्या कर रहे हैं शिप और आरटीपी
हिट एंटर और हम क्या करते हैं गो टू
टेलीफोनी
शिप फ्लो अब यह देखो कितने शिप पैकेट्स
हैं अब इनको इनका फ्लो सीक्वेंस चेक करते
हैं। देखो अब इनका हम फ्लो सीक्वेंस देखते
हैं। यहां ध्यान से देखो। यूजर वन है
192.1 168 20 132 आपका सर्वर है 192 168
20 130 एक यूजर टू आपका क्या 192 168 20.1
उसके बाद थर्ड यूजर क्या आपका?
192.168.20.136
टोटल तीन हो गए। अभी देखो यहां पर
रजिस्ट्रेशन प्रोसेस चल रहा है।
यह आपका रजिस्ट्रेशन प्रोसेस है। किसका?
यूजर वन का जो 132 है IP एड्रेस है लास्ट
में वह किससे रजिस्टर कर रहा है? सर्वर के
साथ। यहां पर फिर जो 192.168.20.1
जो यूजर टू है या यूजर बी है या कॉलर बी
है वो रजिस्टर करने की कोशिश कर रहा है।
किसके साथ? सर्वर के साथ। यहां पे उसने
रजिस्ट्रेशन अपना प्रोसेस कंप्लीट कर
लिया। या इसने भी रजिस्टर कर लिया। उसके
बाद यह थर्ड यूजर है। कौन सा?
192.168.20.130
इसने यह भी क्या करा? अपना रजिस्ट्रेशन
प्रोसेस कंप्लीट करा। रजिस्टर अन ऑथोराइज
रजिस्टर 200 ओके। मतलब यहां तक क्या किया?
तीनों यूज़र्स ने सक्सेसफुली सर्वर के साथ
रजिस्टर कर लिया। जब तीनों यूजर ने
सक्सेसफुली सर्वर के साथ रजिस्टर कर लिया।
उसके बाद देखो इनवाइट एसडीपी पैकेट किसने
भेजा? 132 जॉइन होने की कोशिश किया उसने।
ठीक है? अब एचडीपी में देखेंगे कि किसको
कॉल करने की कोशिश की जा रही है। तो देखिए
हम देखते हैं फिर एसडीपी पैकेट को एनालाइज
करते हैं। तो यहां पर देखोगे पैकेट यह रहा
मैसेज हेडर में। इसने किसको कॉल किया? 44
44। ठीक है? अब 44 44 किसका होगा वो हमें
देखना पड़ेगा वन वन से। उसके बाद देखोगे
कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल चल रही है यहां पर। देन
उसके बाद गो टू दिस वन। नेक्स्ट यहां पर
क्या है? 401 एकनॉलेजमेंट। यहां पर
डाइजेस्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन सक्सेसफुल हो गया।
मतलब डाइजेस्ट चैलेंज दिया था। यहां पर
डाइजेस्ट का रिप्लाई किया गया है। उसके
बाद 100 टाइपिंग 200 एचडीपी 200 एचडीपी
किसकी तरफ से आया? यह सर्वर की तरफ से।
यहां पर किसकी तरफ से आया? सर्वर की तरफ
से। फिर एकनॉलेजमेंट अपडेट फिर 200 ये
रहा। देन यहां आप भी देख सकते हो। एक और
चीज हमारे लिएेंट रहती है। यहां पर यहां
पर एक एक और चीज क्याेंट होती है कि देखो
यहां तक अभी तक पोर्ट सही है। तो यह आपका
पहला आरटीपी पैकेट है। यह पहला आपका
आरटीपी पैकेट है। यहां से इसको रिसेप्शन
हुआ है। ठीक है? सर्वर की तरफ और यहां पर
देखो पोर्ट चेंज हो गया। सबको पता है कि
पोर्ट की इनेशन कब एक्सचेंज होती है।
पोर्ट की इंफॉर्मेशन एक्सचेंज होती है
ड्यूरिंग ड्यूरिंग
ड्यूरिंग एसडीपी। सेशन एसडीपी आपको बताया
था मैं सेशन डिस्क्रिप्शन प्रोटोकॉल यहां
पर क्या है पूरा मीडिया डिस्क्रिप्शन दिया
जाता है तो यहां रहा उसी प्रकार से यहां
पर देखिए इनवाइट एसडीपी इसकी तरफ से आया
है अब की बार देखो यह सर्वर तक ही है फिर
से इनवाइट एसडीपी अब क्या कॉलर टू ने किया
एकनॉलेजमेंट एसडीपी ये ये यहां पर देखोगे
चलो हो गया आरटीपी इन्होंने भी क्या
आरटीपी पैकेट भेज दिया यह कॉलर थ्री है
कॉलर थ्री आया उसके बाद इसने भी इनवाइट
पैकेट भेजा किसको क्योंकि यह कॉन्फ्रेंस
कॉल कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल में यह भी बोलने की
कोशिश कर रहा है। समझ में आ गया? 4G अन
ऑथराइज एकनॉलेजमेंट इनवाइट एसडीपी 100
ट्राइंग यह रहा। ओके। उसके बाद क्या हुआ
कि ऑप्शंस 200 ओके ऑप्शंस 200 ओके बीच में
इनका कनेक्शन चलता रहा। उसके बाद बाय यह
छोड़ के चला गया। पहला पहले यूजर थ्री
छोड़ के चला गया। उसके बाद यूजर टू ने बाय
बोल दिया। फिर इसके बाद यूजर थ्री ने सॉरी
यूजर थ्री ने बाय बोला। यूजर टू ने बाय
बोला। यूजर वन ने बाय बोला। उसके बाद क्या
किया? यह हैंडशक कंप्लीट। मतलब बाय बोलने
के बाद आपकी कॉल टर्मिनेट होगी।
कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल टर्मिनेट होगी। फिर से यह
रीरजिस्टर कर रहे हैं। सबसे पहले कौन
रीरजिस्टर कर रहा है अपने आपको? कॉलर 3
क्योंकि सबसे पहले उसने बाय बोला था। यह
इसने रीरजिस्टर कर लिया। फिर इसने
रीरजिस्टर कर लिया। फिर इसने रीजिस्टर कर
लिया। यह चीज़ सबको क्लियर है? यह पूरा
हैंडशक या जो फ्लो आपको दिखाई दे रहा है,
सबको क्लियर है? यह चीज़ मैं आपको पढ़ा चुका
हूं। इसमें कुछ भी नया नहीं है। यह सबको
क्लियर है? जल्दी से चैट में बताइए। यह
चीज सबको क्लियर है?
यह चीज आप सबको क्लियर है या नहीं है? यह
बताओ।
यह सबको क्लियर है।
बिल्कुल क्लियर है।
चलो अच्छी बात है। तो अभी इसको हम एनालाइज
करने की कोशिश करते हैं। एक्सपोर्ट करें
तो एक्सपोर्ट करने का फायदा नहीं है। इधर
से हम इसको क्या करते हैं? अभी क्लोज करते
हैं। हमने इसको क्लोज किया। उसके बाद एक
और स्क्रीन ओपन हो रखी है यहां पर। इसको
भी हम क्या कर सकते हैं?
यह रहा। गो टू टेलीफोनी। गो टू शिप फ्लो।
ओके ओके बाय मिस्टेक यह गलत स्क्रीन ओपन
कर रखी है। कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल को हम फिर से
ओपन करते हैं। ओपन किया गो टू टेलीफोनी
शिफ्ट फ्लो सेलेक्ट ऑल यहां पर प्ले
स्ट्रीम करके देखते हैं हम अब की बार। यह
देखो इतने इतनी सारी कॉल्स हैं। अभी देखते
हैं कि क्या वायरस शार्क में ये चीज रन हो
पा रही है या नहीं हो पा रही। उसके अलावा
फिर मैं एक टूल्स और बताऊंगा क्योंकि देखो
मैंने आपको क्या दिखाया? पिकैप टू वेव दो
तरीके से बताया। एक तो हमने जो वेबसाइट के
थ्रू मतलब वेब के थ्रू दूसरा मैंने आपको
बताया लinक्स में कमांड के थ्रू लinक्स
में कमांड के थ्रू क्या प्रॉब्लम आ रही है
क्योंकि वर्चुअलाइज मशीन है वर्चुअल मशीन
है वहां पर क्या है सही से कन्वर्ट नहीं
हो पा रहा है या कर नहीं पा रहा ये उसके
बाद क्या है कि जब हमारे पास एक बेस्ट
ऑप्शन है हमें बेसिकली क्या है डॉट वेव
फाइल में कन्वर्ट करना है तो कमांड के
बजाय जब मेरा ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफेस से
काम चल रहा है तो मैं ग्राफिकल यूजर
इंटरफेस से काम चलाऊंगा उसके अलावा क्या
है कि जब हम उसकी जो एम जो ऑडियो फाइल्स
है। जब उन पे क्लिक करते हैं तो हमें पता
नहीं चल रहा कि जैसे यहां पर ग्राफ आ रहा
है कि किस ग्राफ में कहां पर ऑडियो है।
किस कहां पर ऑडियो नहीं है। लेकिन वहां पर
हम ब्लैंक है। हम वेट कर रहे हैं कब ऑडियो
आएगी। तो उसका भी एक अल्टरनेट टूल है। वो
हम देखने वाले हैं। पहले यहां पर रन करके
देखते हैं कि मेरे को बताना सबको सुनाई
दिया या नहीं दिया।
देयर इज करली वन अदर पार्टिसिपेंट इन द
कॉन्फ्रेंस
देयर आर करली टू अदर पार्टिसिपेंट्स इन द
दिस वन वेलकम टूडमी
दिस इज कॉलर टू वेलकम टू अडमी
दिस
वेलकम टूमी
शायद सबको सुनाई दिया होगा। बिल्कुल
क्लियर सुनाई दिया?
सबको ऑडियो क्लियर सुनाई दिया? इट्स ओके।
अब एक काम करते हैं हम। इसको क्लोज करते
हैं। अभी एक नया तरीका इसको भी क्लोज करते
हैं क्योंकि आज हमारा लास्ट है। इसको भी
क्लोज किया हमने। हम चलते हैं यहां पर।
इसको डिलीट किया। एक फाइल ऐड करने वाले
हैं। कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल थ्री पार्टीज ओपन
किया। तो यह देखना अभी एनालाइज कर दिया
जल्दी से। और वॉइस मेल वाले को डिलीट कर
देते हैं। इसको हम क्या करते हैं? क्लिक
किया। यहां पर आ गई। 1 2 देखो 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 हम सबको डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं यहां पर
पहले डाउनलोड में ये जो फाइलें थी मैं
इनको डिलीट कर देता हूं वही ये रहा मेरा
डिलीट कर दिया इनको डिलीट करने से पहले एक
एक टूल है मेरे पास देखो ओडस ओडेसिटी एक
ओडेसिटी टूल है मैंने इस पे क्लिक किया इस
टूल को आप क्या कर सकते हो linux में भी
डाउनलोड कर सकते हो Windows में भी
डाउनलोड कर सकते हो मैं यहां पे क्या
करूंगा डाउनलोड फॉर Windows यहां पे जाओगे
और आप Windows के लिए डाउनलोड कर सकते हो
फ्री है ओपन सोर्स है। आप इसको यूज़ कर
सकते हो। मैंने रिजेक्ट किया। तो जैसे
डाउनलोड करोगे, आप सक्सेसफुली इसको
डाउनलोड कर पाओगे। और यह इस तरीके का
आइकॉन कैसा आता है इसका? यह रहा। डबल
क्लिक करोगे। यह आपका ऑडेसिटी टूल है।
इसके लिए आपको डॉट वेव फाइल चाहिए। इसके
लिए आपको क्या चाहिए? डॉट वेव फाइल। तो,
एक काम करता हूं मैं सबसे पहले यहां पर
उसको इंस्टॉल कर इनको डाउनलोड कर लेता
हूं। डाउनलोड करता हूं। 1
4 5
6 7
8 सारी फाइल डाउनलोड कर ली मैंने यहां पर
बिल्कुल परफेक्ट अभी हम क्या करेंगे यहां
पर फाइल पे जाएंगे फाइल पे जाएंगे यहां पर
हम इंपोर्ट इंपोर्ट ऑडियो देखो ध्यान से
फाइल पर गए
यहां पर हमने क्या किया ओएसटी को ओपन किया
ओपन करके गो टू फाइल गो टू इंपोर्ट ऑप्शन
एंड ऑडियो जैसे ऑडियो पर जाएंगे हम कहां
पर जाएंगे अपने
दिस पीसी डाउनलोड के अंदर
दिस पीसी डाउनलोड
ओके ये रहा डाउनलोड्स गो टू डाउनलोड्स ये
रही वन
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 और इनको हमने क्या कर दिया
ओपन कर दिया ये सारी की सारी फाइलें इसमें
ओपन हो जाएंगी ध्यान से देखोगे तो
आठ की आठ इसमें ओपन हो जाएंगी। ध्यान से
देखोगे तो यह रहा हो गया आठ की आठ ओपन।
अभी बिल्कुल सब कुछ आप देखो कोई इसमें काम
कर सकते हो। सारे इफेक्ट भी डाल पाओगे।
इनमें एडिट कर सकते हो इन वॉइस को एक
प्रकार से। वो है ये एडिटर वॉइस एडिटर एक
प्रकार से। ऐसा कुछ नहीं है। तो अभी हम
क्या कर सकते हैं? इसको रन भी कर सकते
हैं।
अभी तक हम इसको प्ले नहीं किया हमने। तो
यहां पर चलते हैं हम अभी।
सॉरी हम इसको प्ले करते हैं। देखते हैं
कैसे सुनाई देगा।
समझ में आ गया
क्लियर हो गया है प्रोफेशनल चीजें या नहीं
नहीं है बताओ
चीजें प्रोफेशनल है या नहीं है हम इनफैक्ट
इफेक्ट आते हैं इन पे बहुत कुछ है ठीक है
जैसे ये रहा सोलो या उसके बाद देखो
सिर्फ ये अकेला रन करेगा बाकी कोई नहीं
अकेले ऑडियो सुना शायद
ओके इसमें इशू क्या था कि मेरी तरफ से ही
यह क्या कर रहा है यह सॉफ्टवेयर वो नहीं
कर
ओके प्रॉब्लम इसमें यह थी कि मेरे माइक के
थ्रू ही आपको सुनाई दे सकता है। वैसे
सुनाई नहीं देगा। समझ में आ गया? कुछ भी
सुनाई नहीं देता। मेरे माइक के थ्रू ही
सुनाई देगा। तो इट्स ओके। आई विल ट्राई वन
मोर वन मोर टाइम। मैं आपको माइक के थ्रू
सुनाता हूं। ओके? आपको मेरे माइक के थ्रू
सुनाने की कोशिश करता हूं। चलो।
अपने माइक को इनके स्पीकर पे लगाता हूं
मैं। ओके तो ध्यान से सुनना।
सर
अभी तो सुनाई दिया होगा।
अभी तो सबको सुनाई दिया होगा।
अभी तो सुनाई दिया होगा या नहीं दिया?
बताओ।
अभी सुनाई दिया।
थोड़ा सा देखिए एक तो यह तरीका था। बाकी
वायस आर्क में सबको सुनाई दिया था ना
या वस आर्क में भी नहीं सुनाई दिया था।
देखो इसमें सब कुछ क्लियर सुनाई दे रहा
है। बिल्कुल एक-एक ट्यून को आप पकड़ सकते
हो। जैसे इसको है मैं इसको सोलो कर करके
भी सुन सकता हूं। लेफ्ट राइट इसमें बहुत
सारी चीज मॉडिफिकेशन भी कर सकते हो इस टूल
में। यह चीज है। बट मैं आपको बता रहा था
वैसे ही। ठीक है? तो यह है आपका एक
परफेक्ट टूल है जिसको आप यूज़ कर सकते हो
क्योंकि मेरे स्पीकर पे था यह क्योंकि आप
लोग इसको यूज़ करोगे कोई भी वॉइस इसके अंदर
सुनने की कोशिश करोगे तो आपको सब कुछ
क्लियर सुनाई देगा ऐसा नहीं कि आपको कुछ
भी सुनाई नहीं देगा आपको बिल्कुल सब कुछ
क्लियर सुनाई देगा तो आज का टॉपिक क्लियर
हो गया सबको
सबको आज का टॉपिक क्लियर हो गया दूसरा
क्या कर सकते थे कि आप यह हमने यहां से
ऑडियो फाइल को डाउनलोड कर लिया सेम तरीके
से क्या कहां से कर सकते थे हम इसमें
जो अपना लinक्स था लinक्स में भी जो मैंने
कमांड बताई थी सेम कमांड का यूज करते आप
वहां से भी क्या कर सकते हो inside डॉट
वेव फाइल को डाउनलोड कर सकते हो लेकिन अभी
ड्यू टू वर्चुअलाइजेशन मे बी नॉट वर्किंग
प्रॉपर्ली
तो यह था आज का हमारा छोटा सा टॉपिक
ज्यादा बड़ा टॉपिक नहीं था क्योंकि मैं
नेक्स्ट जो मेरा टॉपिक रहेगा इसी में
शिफ्ट ओवर टीएलएस प्लस में आरटीपी मतलब कि
जो आपका सिग्नलिंग या जो आपके हैंडशक है
वह इंक्रिप्टेड होंगे और जो आपका आरटीपी
जो वॉइस डाटा है वह अनइंकिप्टेड होगा। तो
यह वाला जो सिनेरियो है मैं आज स्टार्ट कर
सकता था बट उसका कोई फायदा नहीं होगा
बिकॉज़ दो चीजें एक साथ मर्ज हो जाएंगी
जिसकी वजह से आप कंफ्यूज हो जाओगे। मैं
चाहता हूं कि आप लोग कंफ्यूज ना हो। तो आज
का छोटा सा टॉपिक आप लोगों को कैसा लगा?
सबको समझ में आया आज का टॉपिक?
यह छोटा सा टॉपिक आप लोगों को समझ में आया
सब कुछ?
आई होप सबको समझ में आया होगा। सबको अच्छा
लगा होगा।
मुझे लगता है कि आज का टॉपिक थोड़ा सा
बोरिंग हो सकता है क्योंकि स्टार्टिंग में
थोड़ी सी कुछ चीजें कि आपके लिए रिपीटेशन
में चली गई थी जो आप लोगों को पहले से पता
था। मैं आपको जो समझाने की कोशिश कर रहा
था। वह आपका रिपीटेड हो गया। तो उसकी वजह
से हो सकता है कि आप लोग को क्लास में मजा
नहीं आया हो। बट उसके बाद हमने जो वॉइस
मेल जो कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल को का जो ट्रैफिक
एनालिसिस किया वो शायद अभी सबको समझ में आ
गया होगा।
ओके। तो किसी को कोई डाउट है क्लास
रिलेटेड?
कोई भी डाउट नहीं है किसी का?
यस बोलो।
यस पेंटस जो आपका नाम आप बोलो
पता नहीं क्या बोल अच्छा इनक्रीज में
क्लास वन ऊपर हो और यह 57 या 58 नीचे हो
कैसे बोल रहे हो सुमित मिश्रा
तो
बधाई हो आपको पेन टेस्ट तो आपकी जॉब लगने
के बाद भी आप पढ़ने के लिए आ रहे हो अच्छी
बात है। एंड मेनी मेनी कांग्रेचुलेशन
आपको बहुत-बहुत बधाई है। अगर आपकी जॉब मिल
गई तो
हम भी चाहते हैं कि आपकी तरह बाकी लोगों
को भी मिल जाए।
सुमित मिश्रा क्या बताने की कोशिश कर रहे
थे आप?
सुमित मिश्रा मैं आपको एक चीज बताया। अब
स्टार्टिंग में नहीं था इसलिए मैं आपको
बता देता हूं। क्लास की फ्रीक्वेंसी सिर्फ
स्टूडेंट्स पर डिपेंड करती है। मैं हर
अल्टरनेट डे पर भी क्लास ले सकता हूं।
ओके?
मैं अल्टरनेट डे पर भी क्या कर सकता हूं?
क्लासेस ले सकता हूं। बट जब आपकी
फ्रीक्वेंसी नहीं है ना आप लोग
का जब साथ ही नहीं है मेरे साथ तो मैं
नहीं ले सकता। आप लोग इस पर इंटरेस्ट
दिखाइए। क्लास की फ्रीक्वेंसी बढ़ाइए। आप
यह बताओ कि नौ स्टूडेंट्स से 9 से 15
स्टूडेंट्स।
इतने इससे ज्यादा तो मेरे पेड बैच में आ
जाते हैं।
फ्री में उसके हाफ भी नहीं है। 10% भी
नहीं है।
तो आप यह बताओ कि मैं कैसे क्या करूं? आप
लोग खुद से बताओ मेरी जगह चलो बाकी को
छोड़ो। आप मेरी जगह अपने आप को रखो। क्या
आप अपने आप को इतना मोटिवेट कर पाते?
बिल्कुल सही बोल रहे हो। सुमित मिश्रा आप
गलत नहीं बोल रहे।
बट मुझे इतना भी पता है कि सीरियस लर्नर
भी बहुत ज्यादा है। जिनको सच में जरूरत है
मैं चाहता हूं वो आए वो इसमें इंटरेस्ट
दिखाएं और ऐसा हो नहीं सकता कि सीरियस
लर्नर ओनली इतने ही हैं। ऐसा नहीं हो
सकता।
मुझे वह चाहिए। देखो बात ऐसी है कि आप
अपने क्लासेस की फ्रीक्वेंसी बढ़ाने के
लिए ऐसे स्टूडेंट्स को ना लेकर आए जिन्हें
कोई इंटरेस्ट नहीं है। जस्ट फॉर देयर जस्ट
प्रेजेंटिंग देयर अटेंडेंस नोट मैं वो
चाहता हूं कि स्टूडेंट ऐसे हो कि वो
कंटीन्यूअसली इधर पढ़े। उनको हमेशा नई-नई
चीजें सीखने को मिले। मेरे को भी इंटरेस्ट
आए आप लोगों को पढ़ाने में, आप लोगों के
लिए नई-नई चीजें क्रिएट करने में और जब जब
मैं जो भी वर्कशॉप आपके लिए लेकर आऊं चाहे
फ्री हो, चाहे पेड हो या कोई भी लेकर आए।
मतलब आप उसमें दिल से आओ, दिल से अटेंड
करो और सक्सेस हो जाओ। दैट इज द मेन गोल।
यह हमें मेरा या हमारी जो ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस
है, उसका मेन गोल यह है। हम चाहते हैं कि
आप लोग ज्यादा पैसे वेस्ट ना करो। यह चीज
है।
शुभम कुमार पांडे अगर आप बिल्कुल जीरो से
हो तो स्टार्टिंग से क्लास को स्टार्ट कर
लीजिए। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं। डे वन से
स्टार्ट कर लीजिए।
तो सुमित मिश्रा वेरी अच्छी बात है। अगर
12th में सारी चीजें सीख रहे हो तो आपकी
ग्रेजुएशन बहुत मस्त जाने वाली है। और मैं
उम्मीद कर सकता हूं कि आप
क्या करोगे कि
जब आप ग्रेजुएशन कर रहे होंगे ना बीसीए,
बीटेक व्हाटएवर इन द साइबर सिक्योरिटी
फील्ड आप लोगों को औरों से बहुत ज्यादा
नॉलेज होगी और आपको पता होगा आपका एक विज़न
होगा ना बिल्कुल क्लियर होगा कि मुझे ओके
अभी नेक्स्ट चीज क्या सीखनी है लोग उस
टाइम पर फंडामेंटल कर रहे होंगे किस में
ग्रेजुएशन में उस टाइम पर आप एडवांस में
जा रहे होंगे
इट्स ओके तो फिर क्लास को एंड करें।
चलिए फिर तो आज का सेशन यहीं पर एंड करते
हैं। चलिए देखते हैं कि कल के सेशन में
कितने लोग और आएंगे। कल भी एक सेशन लूंगा
मैं आप लोगों का और सेम व की जो एक साइड
इंक्रिप्शन दूसरी साइड
प्लेन टेक्स्ट वो चीज हम कंपेयर करेंगे।
उस पे भी एनालिसिस परफॉर्म करेंगे। तो
देखते हैं कल की क्लास में कितने लोग
आएंगे। तो सी यू गाइस एंड बाय-ब एंड गुड
नाइट एवरीवन। अगर किसी के कोई भी डाउट
नहीं है तो हम सेशन को एंड करते हैं और कल
की क्लास में मिलते हैं। बाय-ब सी यू एंड
गुड नाइट एवरीवन।